and also in Atlanta this star was being
honored the late rapper takeoff
his cousin and former band made offset
with cardi B were seen heading to State
Farm Arena to pay tribute to the
youngest member of Migos as many as 20
000 fans poured in this is the funeral
procession and a copy of the program
from today's service walk it like a tuck
it Drake who collaborated with the group
on walk it talk it was also on hand his
private plane Air Drake was spotted in
Atlanta the singer rescheduled his show
this weekend to attend the memorial
forever balanced
whenever he would take his Shades off he
had this thing about him that I love no
matter what was going on around us he
was like always
kind of squinting but like his eyes were
wide open Justin Bieber was among the
names expected at the service as well
fellow rapper De Brat shared video from
outside the arena today all right Pete
take off we love you bro
five shots fired downstairs
police are still searching for takeoff's
killer the 28 year old was shot outside
this Houston bowling alley 10 days ago
I swear takeoff's family had asked in
lieu of flowers or gifts that donations
be made to the rocket Foundation to
prevent gun violence his impact will
never be forgotten something we talked
about last year you are affecting
culture across pop music everywhere who
doesn't understand who needs to know you
know we don't need to know if you you
know I'm saying if you're part of the
culture and a part of hip-hop and music
you need to know
[Music]
foreign